[Music]
Alex going to college mostly pretty
psyched right so you spin us three it's
gonna be like it's just us this is gonna
be filled with our love it give me a
regular [ __ ] this oh yeah you ever get
your passport ready cuz word when we
going to [ __ ] down when I became a dad I
made a choice to support my daughter's
dreams you don't have enough money fifty
million dollars thousand honey oh you
guys need money I know how to get let's
start an underground casino I don't like
this check this out look at Alex here
she is she's gone to college if she
doesn't go boom
she's a homeless prostitute on the
streets selling her tiny body for money
you want to make money like Vegas you
got a look like Vegas we've got a nail
salon massages you're never gonna
believe what's in this next room is it a
strip club hey we're gonna make crazy
than money
we gotta invite everybody hey there's
something going on in this town
your mother and I will be working late I
just can't help but feel like you're
lying you've been coming home late every
night smelling like smoke and bruised
honey yeah I'm just gonna lie down check
some emails you guys to shut down this
casino guys we got a problem
I've sent a message like dinero casino
do you think you can cheat us I got
lucky because me and my friends about to
[ __ ] you up what are you guys gonna do
about it anyway you're a bunch of soccer
moms tell your friends say mr. de souza
you're gonna get
[Music]